in this lesson we're going to talk about
slope and slope you know rears its uh
ugly head in a lot of different uh forms
and fashions throughout the act whether
it's the slope intercept form of the
line whether it's just finding the slope
of a a line from an equation whether
it's trying to find a parallel lines
looking at their slopes or perpendicular
lines so slope is definitely an
important concept you want to understand
for the a c t so let's kind of go
through a little bit more here we've got
y equals mx plus b that's the slope
intercept form of the line the number
that comes in front of the the x value
here is the slope that's m and this is
only uh applicable when y is by itself
when it's in this y equals mx plus b
form and then the formula for the slope
we talked about uh in another section y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 that's the
rise over the run
and when you're working with parallel
lines you know the reason that they're
parallel and they don't cross is because
they're going up at the same angle or
the same slope but when they're
perpendicular then the slopes are
opposite reciprocal so what i mean by
that is like say if one of the slopes is
three which is like 3 over 1 you would
take the reciprocal which is 1 3 and
make the sign the opposite now if this
was negative then this one would be
positive so that's what i mean by
opposite reciprocals then the lines are
perpendicular so let's go through a
couple examples go ahead and pause the
video
that's the way you're going to get the
most benefit from you know these
lessons
so go ahead and do this one what is the
slope of the line 2x minus 5y equals 20.
okay well what you want to do is you
want to put it into the slope intercept
form of the line and i'm going to do
that by getting the y by itself so i'm
going to subtract 2x from both sides
okay so that gives us negative 5y equals
negative 2x plus 20. then i want to get
this y by itself so i'm going to do the
opposite of multiplying by negative five
i'm going to divide everything by
negative five so you can see y equals
two-fifths x minus four
and the two negatives here are canceling
so you just get a positive two-fifths as
your slope of your line
okay so very important you don't want to
you know
jump to conclusions too fast before you
get that y by itself
and you get everything else on the other
side you just want to solve for one y
and then that number in front of the x
is your slope okay example number two it
says what is the slope of the line
that's perpendicular
to this line here ac so this is a and
this is c
well when you're talking about a
perpendicular line you're talking about
a line that's at a right angle which
remember that's the opposite reciprocal
slope of this line here so let's go
ahead and find the slope of this line
i'm going to use the slope formula here
i'm going to do that by doing
y2 minus y1 so negative 1 minus 2 over
x2 minus x1 that's 3 minus negative 1.
now a lot of times students make a
mistake where they'll put the x's in the
numerator and the y's in the denominator
because we're thinking x y z or we're
thinking of left to right but you want
to make sure that you put the y's in the
numerator x's in the denominator the
only the other thing you want to pay
attention to is that you know when
you're subtracting that's like adding
the opposite so here i'm subtracting
that's like adding the opposite so now
we have negative one plus negative two
is negative three three plus one is four
that's the slope of this line you wanna
make sure you don't put that as your
answer right okay when you're picking
the multiple choice options you really
want the opposite reciprocal so the
opposite sign is going to be positive
and the reciprocal is going to be
four thirds i just flip that over
so that's how you would solve this
problem
slope is definitely an important concept
you want to understand for the math
section of the ect i'll see in the next
lesson